nous sommes très sensibles à la
situation des croyants dans notre pays
et particulièrement dans cette crise qui
est une période difficile qui est une
période éprouvante pour l'ensemble du
pays et qui conduit nécessairement nous
savons tous les croyants à vouloir se
retrouver à vouloir se recueillir à
vouloir prier peut-être plus encore et
comment ne pas avoir une pensée pour nos
compatriotes catholique après l'attentât
de nice vous le savez la situation
sanitaire nous a conduits à prendre une
décision difficile celle du confinement
pour limiter les risques de
contamination avec une fermeture des
établissements recevant du public pour
des raisons sanitaires pour protéger
tous les français pour autant parce que
nous sommes attachés au respect des
libertés et notamment au respect de la
liberté de culte nous avons décidé de
maintenir les lieux de culte ouverts et
de permettre que les cérémonies
religieuses ils soient célébrés pour
être diffusé à distance je sais bien que
cette situation est très imparfaite et
qu'elle ne permet pas à tout le monde de
pouvoir accéder à ces cérémonies nous
avons souhaité aussi autoriser les
cérémonies d'enterrement dans la limite
de 30 personnes ce qui est une évolution
par rapport à ce qui avait été décidé au
début du premier confinement afin que
chacun puisse vivre dignement son deuil
cette situation je le disais à l'instant
reste imparfaite et nous le savons le
conseil d'état l'a confirmé nous savons
que les restrictions sont durs et croyez
bien que notre souhait est qu'elle
puisse être levée dès que ce sera
possible c'est la raison pour laquelle
je peux vous annoncer qu'une réunion se
tiendra au ministère de l'intérieur dès
le début de semaine prochaine pourra
probablement dès lundi prochain qu elle
associera les représentants des cultes
l'objectif de cette réunion sera à la
fois d'aborder les précisions que vous
avez évoquées qui sont demandés mais
également aussi de dessiner ensemble dès
maintenant les conditions dans
lesquelles les cultes pourront à nouveau
recevoir du public dès lors qu'un
assouplissement sera possible c'est un
travail que nous devons mener dès
maintenant car dès que ce sera possible
nous avons le souhait évidemment de
pouvoir permettre aux croyants de
rejoindre les lieux de culte vous le
voyez nous sommes extrêmement mobilisés
nous allons construire ses solutions
avec les représentants des cultes